they started getting bought up so you
might buy uh five stations in the
Midwest and then you buy another 10 more
and you you cover the Northwest and
that's when things get really um
repetitive because I I even today I get
my news clippings every day and I'll see
a story about me and then I watch it on
another station halfway across the state
or across the country and it's the exact
same script different anchors are
reading it because it's one conglomerate
who owns all those stations and that one
script that's coming from the top
conglomerate to say these are the words
we're using that and it's on the
teleprompt you just read it right but
now this is the difference you know we
when I worked for Fox we would get those
same things the clips would come down
from wherever across the country other
other stations were doing stories they
would come to us the script is already
written you can rewrite scripts if you
are have a good work ethic or you don't
like what they say you can rewrite them
so that it is different I didn't want to
just be repeating the same words as
somebody across the country you want to
look at that script and make sure it's
written properly not all anchors do that